This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In 2020, journalist Lauren Ober received a somewhat unexpected diagnosis. An autism diagnosis, to be exact. And unexpected because I'm a very middle-aged lady. I'm loud and physical, and I don't exactly fit any of the autistic stereotypes. Nerdy, quiet, indoors, unathletic, into video games, and unable to sustain eye contact? That's not me. But then I learned that those are stereotypical male autistic traits, gleaned from years of research on autistic men and boys. Autism in women and girls has historically been overlooked. And because of that, my neurodivergent sisters and I didn't realize that we could be so much more
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。2020年，记者劳伦·奥贝尔得到了一个多少有点意料之外的确诊结果。准确地说，是孤独症确诊。之所以意料之外，是因为我是一个非常中年的女士。我声音洪亮、肢体动作多，而且我完全不符合任何孤独症的刻板印象。书呆子气、安静、宅、不爱运动、沉迷电子游戏、无法维持眼神交流？那不是我。但后来我了解到，这些都是刻板的男性孤独症特征，是从多年对孤独症男性和男孩的研究中收集来的。女性和女孩的孤独症在历史上一直被忽视。正因如此，我和我的神经多样性姐妹们并没有意识到，我们可以比
than those tired autistic tropes, but we can. And when I understood that, the cloud sort of lifted for me. A lot of the pieces of my life started to click into place. Lauren even made a podcast about her experience called The Loudest Girl in the World. And she found herself imagining a fantasy world where everything is tailored to Lauren's very specific autistic needs. I call this world autism pleasant, Phil. And it wouldn't have sirens or fireworks or people talking loudly on their phones in public. Also no oppressively bright overhead lighting or spaces pumped with artificial fragrance.
那些陈旧的孤独症刻板印象要丰富得多，但我们的确可以。当我明白这一点时，我心中的阴霾仿佛消散了。我生活中的许多片段开始各就各位。劳伦甚至制作了一档关于她经历的播客，名叫《世界上声音最大的女孩》。她发现自己想象着一个奇幻世界，那里的一切都是为劳伦非常具体的孤独症需求量身定制的。我把这个世界称为“孤独症乐土”，菲尔。这里没有警笛、烟花，也没有人在公共场合大声讲电话。同样也没有压抑刺眼的头顶照明，或是弥漫着人工香精的空间。
And the foot traffic flow of public spaces would be such that I wasn't constantly touching strangers. Some of these stimuli can be irritating or unpleasant for neurotypical people, but they have the potential to be debilitating for people with sensory issues. Which is why autism pleasantville wasn't some throwaway fantasy for me. And obviously, there's not a one-size-fits-all diagnosis or even definition of autism. Or as the autism adage goes, if you know one autistic person, you know one autistic person.
公共空间的脚底交通流向应该是不至于让我不断触碰到陌生人的那种。其中一些刺激对神经典型人群来说可能是令人烦恼或不愉快的，但它们有可能让有感觉统合问题的人感到虚弱。这就是为什么“孤独症乐土”对我来说不是什么随意的幻想。很显然，并没有千篇一律的孤独症诊断，甚至连孤独症的定义也没有。正如孤独症俗语所说，如果你认识一个孤独症患者，你就只认识一个孤独症患者。
But, despite our wide variety of needs, I wanted to know how design is evolving to better accommodate us. So, autism and neurodivergence are considered disabilities under the ADA, which means that they are protected by the ADA. I talked with Elio McCabe, Policy Manager for the Autistic Women and Non-binary Network. Elio is autistic and also a lawyer with an expertise in disability rights. So accommodating neurodivergent and autistic people often means thinking a lot about their sensory needs. So what we're seeing now is a bit of a movement
但是，尽管我们的需求千差万别，我还是想了解设计是如何演变以更好地适应我们的。因此，孤独症和神经多样性在《美国残疾人法案》（ADA）下被视为残疾，这意味着它们受到ADA的保护。我采访了孤独症女性和非二元性别网络（AWN）的政策经理埃利奥·麦凯布。埃利奥本人是孤独症患者，也是一位精通残疾人权利的律师。因此，适应神经多样性和孤独症患者通常意味着要多为他们的感官需求着想。所以我们现在看到的是一场运动，它超越了
beyond just thinking about physical access and thinking a little bit more about other needs. Lauren wanted to know what it looked like to accommodate people with autism and sensory disabilities. And she had recently heard of a certification program meant to highlight when a city is autism-friendly. That designation is what led me to Mesa, Arizona, the world's first autism certified city.
仅仅考虑物理通道，并开始更多地思考其他需求。劳伦想知道适应孤独症和感觉障碍的人是什么样子的。她最近听说了一个认证项目，旨在突出一个城市何时对孤独症友好。正是这个称号把我带到了亚利桑那州梅萨，全球首个获得孤独症认证的城市。
We are the 36th largest city in the United States. And over the past 20 years, especially in the past 15 years, we've just seen explosive growth in Mesa. That's Mark Garcia. He's the CEO of Visit Mesa and possibly the biggest cheerleader for this desert city of more than half a million people just outside of Phoenix. It's flat and expansive and perhaps not a destination you go out of your way to visit. Unless you're a big baseball fan because the Oakland A's and the Chicago Cubs both
我们是美国第三十六大城市。在过去的20年里，特别是在过去的15年里，我们见证了梅萨爆发式的增长。那是马克·加西亚。他是“访问梅萨”旅游局的首席执行官，很可能是这个位于菲尼克斯郊外、拥有五十多万人口的沙漠城市最热情的啦啦队长。这里地势平坦开阔，或许不是那种你会特地跑去旅游的目的地。除非你是棒球迷，因为奥克兰运动家队和芝加哥小熊队都在
have spring training compounds in the city. Mesa's got some other draws, a few casinos nearby, a surprising number of karaoke bars, and golf, if that's your thing. We're probably the largest city a lot of folks haven't heard about. And that's because we've kind of been in the shadow of Phoenix all these years. I can tell you that Mesa has always been a city with a huge heart. In addition to being Mesa's biggest booster, Mark is also the father of an autistic child. And that means that Mark is very familiar with the challenges of traveling while autistic.
这座城市设有春训基地。梅萨还有其他吸引人的地方，附近有几家赌场、数量惊人的卡拉OK酒吧，如果这是你的爱好，还有高尔夫。我们可能是许多人没听说过的最大的城市。那是因为这些年来我们一直生活在菲尼克斯的阴影下。我可以告诉你，梅萨一直是一座充满爱心的城市。除了是梅萨最大的啦啦队队长外，马克还是一个孤独症儿童的父亲。这意味着马克对孤独症患者旅行时所面临的挑战非常熟悉。
Mark remembers this one time when his son was having a meltdown on a family vacation in Southern California. The hospitality staff definitely made matters worse. And we were made to feel unwelcome. We were made to feel uncomfortable, and I'll never forget that feeling. That feeling of being judged for his parenting
马克还记得有一次，他的儿子在南加州的一次家庭度假中大发脾气。酒店员工的行为绝对让情况变得更糟糕。他们让我们感到不受欢迎。他们让我们感到不舒服，我永远不会忘记那种感觉。那种因为他的育儿方式
and for his child's behavior. And it was just the looks that you get. You didn't need verbal language. That feeling of being judged for his parenting and for his child's behavior. And it was just the looks that you get. You didn't need verbal language. The body language itself did all the damage possible. And in some small way, Mark wanted to change that. And I said, you know, I would like to train our hospitality staff in Mesa, at least to recognize and become aware of what autism is. And so that's what I set out to do.
和孩子的行为而被评判的感觉。那种感觉仅仅来自于你得到的眼神。你不需要言语。那种因为他的育儿方式和孩子的行为而被评判的感觉。那种感觉仅仅来自于你得到的眼神。你不需要言语。肢体语言本身就造成了所有可能的伤害。在某种微小的程度上，马克想要改变这一点。我说，你知道的，我想培训我们在梅萨的酒店员工，至少让他们认识并意识到什么是孤独症。这就是我着手去做的事情。
With the support of city officials, Mark's organization, Visit Mesa, rolled out its autism inclusion program for Mesa in 2019. It included itineraries filled with autism-friendly activities in and around the city. Also, professional development for folks in all types of industries in Mesa. Health care, education, hospitality, as well as local government. Then these businesses, civic groups, and government offices did some trainings
在市官员的支持下，马克的机构“访问梅萨”于2019年在梅萨推出了孤独症包容计划。其中包括充满市内及周边孤独症友好活动的行程。此外，还为梅萨各个行业的员工提供专业发展培训。医疗保健、教育、酒店业以及地方政府。随后，这些企业、公民团体和政府办公室通过
through a group called the International Board of Credentialing and Continuing Education Standards. I mean, who doesn't love a good credentialing board? The goal of the trainings was to help organizations meet autistic people where they are. continuing education standards. I mean, who doesn't love a good credentialing board? The goal of the trainings was to help organizations meet autistic people where they are. When Mesa hit a critical mass of businesses that had done the trainings,
一个名为国际credentialing和继续教育标准委员会的组织进行了一些培训。我的意思是，谁不喜欢一个好的认证委员会呢？培训的目标是帮助组织在孤独症患者所在的地方满足他们的需求。继续教育标准委员会。我的意思是，谁不喜欢一个好的认证委员会呢？培训的目标是帮助组织在孤独症患者所在的地方满足他们的需求。当梅萨达到了一定数量完成培训的企业时，
the city was designated an autism certified city. It was really a citywide initiative. And it made good business sense too, because accessibility needs are rarely advanced because of altruism alone. This wasn't just because it was the right thing to do, And it made good business sense too, because accessibility needs are rarely advanced because of altruism alone. This wasn't just because it was the right thing to do, good corporate responsibility. Yes, that was certainly true.
该市被指定为孤独症认证城市。这确实是一项全市范围的倡议。这也符合商业逻辑，因为无障碍需求很少仅仅因为利他主义而得到推进。这不仅仅是因为这是正确的事情，这也符合商业逻辑，因为无障碍需求很少仅仅因为利他主义而得到推进。这不仅仅是因为这是正确的事情，这是一种良好的企业责任。是的，这当然是真的。
But for me, this was a business decision. Because autistic people have money and we want to spend it. Presumably more autism friendly businesses and attractions means more visitors who have neurodivergent kids or who have neurodivergent kids or who are neurodivergent themselves. I mean, that's what brought me to Mesa, and I wanted to put the city's autism-friendliness to the test. But that's kind of hard in practice because why, Roman?
但对我来说，这是一个商业决定。因为孤独症患者有钱，而我们想要花掉它。大概更多孤独症友好的企业和景点意味着会有更多的游客，他们有神经多样性的孩子，或者他们自己就是神经多样性者。我的意思是，这就是把我带到梅萨的原因，我想把该市的孤独症友好程度付诸检验。但在实践中这有点难，为什么呢，罗曼？
If you know one autistic person, you know one autistic person. Correct. So what works for me in terms of noise or lighting or wayfinding or temperature might not work for another autistic person. And it bears mentioning that in addition to having a killer ability to mask, meaning I'm amazing at hiding my weirdo brain differences, I have a subtle presentation of autism. So again, since I'm just one autistic person with one particular opinion,
如果你认识一个孤独症患者，你就只认识一个孤独症患者。没错。因此，就噪音、照明、寻路或温度而言，对我管用的方法可能对另一个孤独症患者不管用。值得一提的是，除了拥有超强的掩饰能力——这意味着我非常擅长隐藏我怪异的大脑差异——我的孤独症表现比较微妙。所以再次强调，既然我只是一个带着特定观点的孤独症患者，
I invited my autistic buddy Thomas Kaufman along to explore Mesa with me. We met at a cafe on the list of autism-friendly establishments. I realized that not only do you have sensitive ears, but you also work in audio. So you're like doubly sensitive to it. I'm like totally tuned into everything that's going on.
我邀请了我的孤独症好友托马斯·考夫曼和我一起探索梅萨。我们在一家名列孤独症友好名单上的咖啡馆碰面。我意识到你不仅耳朵敏感，而且你还从事音频工作。所以你对声音可以说是双倍敏感。我感觉自己对周围发生的一切都完全处于高度调谐状态。
Thomas is a physicist and PhD candidate in auditory and language neuroscience, speech and hearing science, which is a mouthful, but basically means he cares a lot about how things sound. Yeah, I don't think my brain backgrounds anything, like the fridge buzzing in the background here. That doesn't fade into the background. It's just as present as everything else.
托马斯是一名物理学家，也是听觉和语言神经科学、言语和听力科学的博士候选人，这个头衔有点拗口，但基本上意味着他非常关切声音是如何呈现的。是的，我觉得我的大脑不会让任何背景声音淡出，就像这里背景中冰箱的嗡嗡声一样。那不会淡入背景。它和其他所有声音一样真实地存在着。
I have to make a conscious effort to not have that noise impact my auditory processing. The cafe's loud music and overhead fans made for a really hectic soundscape. Also, Thomas really wasn't feeling the visuals. To wit, the bathroom. It's a strobe light. All you see is pink strobing light.
我必须有意识地努力不让那种噪音影响我的听觉处理。咖啡馆嘈杂的音乐和头顶的电扇构成了一个非常混乱的声景。此外，托马斯对视觉效果也实在喜欢不起来。具体来说，就是洗手间。那是频闪灯。你看到的只有粉红色的频闪光。
All this made me wonder what happens in those trainings for autism certification. Like, what are businesses being taught about sensory differences? And have any city stakeholders made an effort to change their physical spaces to accommodate autistic folks? After the coffee shop, Lauren and Thomas headed
这一切让我好奇，在那些为了获得孤独症认证而举办的培训中究竟会发生什么？比如，企业被教导了关于感觉差异的哪些知识？是否有任何城市利益相关者努力改变他们的物理空间来适应孤独症患者？离开咖啡馆后，劳伦和托马斯前往了
to an art center slash museum on the autism certification list. An employee who did not want to be named for reasons that will become obvious later, explain what made the art center autism friendly. Say a blanket. Bright neon stuff. Look at that.
孤独症认证名单上的一家艺术中心兼博物馆。一名出于稍后会显而易见的原因不愿透露姓名的员工解释了是什么让该艺术中心对孤独症友好。比如一条毯子。色彩鲜艳的霓虹物件。看那个。
Sunglasses. Some headphones for children and adults. It was a suitcase of sorts, like a pre-made sensory kit from Amazon. Here's a gallon Ziploc bag with a whole bunch of bright neon plastic toys. That's exactly what I was hoping. Not to mention some very stiff ear defenders, like the kind a landscaper would wear while operating a weed whacker.
太阳镜。为儿童和成人准备的一些耳机。那是一种手提箱，就像从亚马逊预先买好的感官工具包。这里有一个加仑的 ziploc 塑料袋，里面装满了各种色彩鲜艳的霓虹塑料玩具。这正是我所期望的。更不用说一些非常硬的耳罩了，就像园林工人在操作割草机时戴的那种。
Of course, I forced Thomas to model them for me. You look amazing. I mean, there's like a lot of pressure on my head, but it's almost like I feel a suction on my ear canals. So it's not a positive experience for you? No, I'd rather use earplugs. Okay, alright, fair. This idea of an autism-friendly city is relatively new, so there isn't a ton of data to gauge whether these efforts are effective.
当然，我强迫托马斯为我试戴。你看起来棒极了。我的意思是，我的头部承受了很大的压力，但感觉就像我的耳道受到了吸力。所以对你来说这不是一次积极的体验？不，我宁愿用耳塞。好吧，好吧，这倒也是。孤独症友好城市这个概念比较新，所以没有大量的数据来评估这些努力是否有效。
Still, if we give Mesa the benefit of the doubt, it seems like these businesses are trying to do the right thing. But are these accommodations actually helping autistic people? I mean, case in point. Our front desk friend pointed us to an escape space down the hall where one could presumably go
不过，如果我们选择相信梅萨，这些企业似乎是在努力做正确的事情。但这些无障碍设施真的在帮助孤独症患者吗？我的意思是，这就是一个典型的例子。前台的朋友把我们带到大厅尽头的一个逃生空间，人们大概可以去那里，
if they were experiencing sensory overload. That sounds like a good accommodation. You would think that, Roman. Except... Sorry, sorry. Okay, so we're in the toilet right now. We're in the sensory room, which is also the toilet. Just to drive this home, the escape space for people experiencing sensory overload is the accessible bathroom. Cool.
如果他们正在经历感官过载。听起来是个不错的无障碍设施。你会这么想的，罗曼。除了……抱歉，抱歉。好吧，所以我们现在在厕所里。我们在感官室里，这也是个厕所。为了把这一点说清楚，为经历感官过载的人准备的逃生空间竟然是无障碍浴室。太酷了。
How big is this space? Like this is my wingspan, so six feet. Six feet. About six feet. All right. All right. Six square foot space. Okay. And one seating opportunity.
这个空间有多大？就像这是我的臂展，所以有六英尺。六英尺。大约六英尺。好吧。好吧。六平方英尺的空间。好的。还有一个提供座位的机会。
A toilet. If you put the seat down. Without the back, so you can't like rest. No. When I think of calm spaces, a public toilet isn't one of them. This is not a room you would seek out when you're not having a good time. Our front desk friend wanted to be very clear. Having the safe space, calm space be the bathroom is not appropriate.
马桶。如果你把马桶盖放下来的话。没有靠背，所以你没法靠着。没有。当我想到安静的空间时，公共厕所绝不在其中。这不是一个在你过得不开心时会去寻找的房间。我们的前台朋友想要说清楚一点。把安全空间、平静空间设为浴室是不合适的。
Thomas and I left the gallery and headed outside for a little art center postmortem. Well see, now if I go in there, right, like I love galleries. I love art galleries. There's nothing in there that bothers me. It was a very pleasant space. If there's 20 kids in there at the same time, that might be a different situation. I would say that that's, you know, if you're an autistic adult, like, it's a totally reasonable space. I wouldn't ask them for their sensory kit. I was going to say, if it's too loud for you, you can get the earmuffs. I could put on this sunglass.
托马斯和我离开展厅，走到外面，对艺术中心之行进行了一次简短的复盘。你看，现在如果我走进去，对吧，我喜欢画廊。我喜欢艺术画廊。里面没有什么东西让我困扰。那是一个非常宜人的空间。如果里面同时有20个孩子，那可能是另一种情况了。我要说的是，如果你是一个孤独症成年人，这是一个完全合理的空间。我不会向他们索要感官工具包。我正想说，如果声音对你来说太大，你可以拿耳罩。我可以戴上这副太阳镜。
All of this illustrates the challenge of what Visit Mesa is trying to do. Educating folks about autism is just the first step. And Elio McCabe, the disability rights lawyer, says local businesses and organizations could go even further. So what that can look like is dimmer switches, especially in doctors' offices, where you're already really stressed out and you don't want those glaring fluorescent lights on you. Or it can look like putting up tapestries or things on the walls to dim that big echoey noise. Let's also pay attention to the temperature, because radically changing temperatures can really be overwhelming for neurodivergent people.
所有这一切都说明了“访问梅萨”项目所面临的挑战。教育人们了解孤独症只是第一步。残疾人权利律师埃利奥·麦凯布表示，当地企业和组织可以做得更多。这可以表现为调光开关，特别是在医务室里，在那里你已经承受了很大的压力，你不会希望那些刺眼的荧光灯照着你。或者也可以是在墙上挂上挂毯或其他东西来减弱那种巨大的回音。我们还要注意温度，因为剧烈变化的温度对神经多样性人群来说确实是难以承受的。
Some community partners have put the education component into practice. Two of the city's museums posted sensory guides on the walls, indicating how loud or smelly or bright an exhibit might be. One hotel has adjusted its lobby lights to be more friendly on the eyes. But really, what businesses do with that education is beyond Mark's purview. The Mesa Project shows that there are limits
一些社区伙伴已经将教育部分付诸实践。该市的两家博物馆在墙上张贴了感官指南，指明某个展品可能会有多吵、有多大异味或有多亮。一家酒店调整了大堂的灯光，使其对眼睛更加友好。但实际上，企业如何利用这些教育超出了马克的管辖范围。梅萨项目表明，改造空间以使其对孤独症更友好是有限度的，
to retrofitting spaces to make them more autism-friendly. But there are ways to accommodate neurodivergence before a single nail is hammered. It starts by integrating autistic needs into the design process and including autistic people early on in the planning. One architect's doing just that. So my name is Magda Mostafa. I'm a professor of design and architecture for autism. I'm
但在锤下一颗钉子之前，有多种方法可以适应神经多样性。它始于将孤独症患者的需求融入设计过程，并在规划的早期阶段就将孤独症患者纳入其中。一位建筑师正在这样做。所以我叫玛格达·穆斯塔法。我是孤独症设计和建筑学教授。我
also a practicing architect in the area of architecture for autism. Magda's being modest here. She's not only a professor at the American University in Cairo and the founder of an autism and neuro-inclusive architecture firm in Dubai, but she's also one of the leading thinkers on the intersection of autism and architecture. Magda created the world's first set of research-based design guidelines for autism. And it all kind of happened by accident.
也是一名专门从事孤独症建筑领域的实践建筑师。玛格达在这里表现得很谦虚。她不仅是开罗美国大学的教授，也是迪拜一家孤独症和神经包容性建筑公司的创始人，同时她还是孤独症与建筑交汇领域的前沿思想家之一。玛格达创建了世界上第一套基于研究的孤独症设计指南。这一切可以说是偶然发生的。
So it was the classical necessity as the mother of invention. I was approached by a group of parents who had children on the spectrum, young children on the spectrum, were searching for an academic, educational space for their kids and weren't finding something that felt like a good fit for them. Now, it is important to note at this point, Magda didn't have any experience with autism, personally or professionally.
所以这就是所谓的“需求是发明之母”。有一组家长找到我，他们的孩子处于孤独症谱系中，是谱系中的幼儿，他们正在为自己的孩子寻找一个学术教育空间，却没有找到感觉适合他们的场所。现在，有必要指出的是，当时玛格达没有任何关于孤独症的经验，无论是个人还是专业方面。
And I very naively went out and said, okay, great, I'll just look into the references and there will be something in a chapter between wheelchair accessibility and deaf space, and I'll find a chapter on autism, get the guidelines and standards, apply them like a good student, and we're golden. Oh, if only it were that easy. Twenty years ago, when these parents asked Magda to design a school for their children,
我非常天真地走出去说，好吧，太棒了，我只要查查参考资料，在轮椅无障碍设施和聋人空间之间的某一章里就会有关于孤独症的章节，我会找到指南和标准，像个好学生一样应用它们，然后我们就大功告成了。哦，要是真有那么简单就好了。二十年前，当这些家长请玛格达为他们的孩子设计一所学校时，
there weren't any standards or best practices for how to create space for autistic folks. Autism was hardly even talked about. Magda had no reference points. So she created them. I embedded myself in the school for about a year and a half, spent six months just observing and making sure that the kids were comfortable with me in their space. And then we started just tweaking and playing around with things
没有任何关于如何为孤独症患者创造空间的标准或最佳实践。当时几乎没有人谈论孤独症。玛格达没有任何参考点。于是她自己创造了这些参考点。我在学校里呆了一年半左右，花了六个月的时间只是观察，确保孩子们在他们的空间里对我很自在。然后我们开始调整和摆弄一些事情，
and building as we go. That observational work was critical to Magda's process because she was getting a sense of how the autistic kids organically use space, what they gravitated towards, what agitated them, what prompted expressions of joy. For example, in those early classrooms and in those early homes and saw kids reorganizing the sofa cushions so they could tuck under it and hide their head when the TV was on or when their brother was munching their lunch or whatever it was that was happening that was annoying them acoustically, those moments became what we call escape space. Lyle McAllister Magda noticed how ingenious the students were, curating spaces to take care of themselves.
并在实践中不断建设。这种观察工作对玛格达的过程至关重要，因为她一直在了解孤独症儿童如何有机地使用空间，他们倾向于什么，什么让他们烦躁，什么会引发他们表达喜悦。例如，在早期的教室和早期的家庭中，我看到孩子们重新整理沙发垫，这样他们就可以钻到下面去，在看电视或者他们的兄弟在吃午饭，或者无论发生什么在声学上让他们感到烦恼的事情时把头藏起来，那些时刻就变成了我们所说的逃生空间。莱尔·麦卡利斯特玛格达注意到学生们是多么聪明，他们自己策划空间来照顾自己。
She used these findings to inform her design decisions. I call it this autism as expertise model. So what is the expertise that this autistic body is bringing into their own experience? How are they changing their space? The architectural tool Magda formalized based on her observations is called Aspects. That's with two S's at the end. It's an acronym. A stands for acoustics.
她利用这些发现来指导她的设计决策。我称之为“孤独症作为专业知识”模型。那么，这个孤独症群体为他们自己的体验带来了什么专业知识？他们是如何改变他们的空间的？玛格达根据她的观察正式确定的建筑工具被称为Aspects（建筑环境感官设计指南）。结尾有两个S。这是一个首字母缩写词。A代表声学（acoustics）。
I think that's pretty self-explanatory. It's not about creating silent spaces, but it's about allowing sound in an intentional way, not in an accidental way. Give me an SP. SP. SP stands for spatial, as in spatial sequencing, which is about working with routine, making space predictable so you're not jumping all over the place all the time. You're moving seamlessly from one activity to another to another in a sequence. Give me an E. That's for those escape spaces Magda was talking about.
我认为这不言自喻。这不是要创造无声的空间，而是要以一种刻意的方式而不是偶然的方式让声音进入。给我举一个SP的例子。SP。SP代表空间（spatial），也就是空间序列，这是关于顺应日常规律，让空间具有可预测性，这样你就不会一直在各个地方到处乱跑。你是在一个序列中无缝地从一个活动移动到另一个再到另一个。给我举一个E的例子。那是为了玛格达刚才谈到的那些逃生空间。
Give me a. I think that's enough cheerleading. Fair. Okay, so C stands for compartmentalization, where you organize a larger space, like a classroom, into smaller, discrete, and separate spaces. And it's not about creating cubicles or booths or partitions, but it's about clustering like activities with like activities. So like plush carpeting and soft cushions distinguish an escape space, whereas a bookcase
给我举一个A的例子。我觉得啦啦队活动已经够多了。好吧，公平地说。那么C代表空间分区（compartmentalization），即把一个较大的空间（如教室）组织成更小、独立且分开的空间。这并不是要建造隔间、摊位或隔板，而是要把相似的活动与相似的活动聚集在一起。比如毛绒地毯和软垫可以区分出一个逃生空间，而一个书架
and a table with two chairs in a quiet corner can delineate a one-on-one workspace. The T is for transition, like moving from a loud overstimulating space to a quiet focus space. The least we can do is build in a little bit of interstitial transition space, that moment just for sensory regulation for you to take a breath, to readjust, and to set yourself up to be more successful when you enter that next test. And finally, the last two S's. They're safety, which is obvious, then sensory zoning. Basically meaning that spaces should be designed
和一张带两把椅子的桌子在一个安静的角落里可以勾勒出一个一对一的工作空间。T代表过渡（transition），比如从一个嘈杂、过度刺激的空间移动到一个安静、专注的空间。我们能做的最起码的事情就是内置一点点间质过渡空间，那个只为感官调节而设的时刻，让你喘口气，重新调整，并让自己为进入下一个任务做好更充分的准备。最后，最后两个S。它们是安全（safety），这是显而易见的，然后是感官分区（sensory zoning）。基本上意味着应该根据空间的感觉质量来设计空间
based on their sensory quality. So if we think of a school design, a low stimulus, high focus math classroom might go next to a low stimulus, high focus English classroom. High stimulus spaces like a music room or a noisy cafeteria shouldn't be in the same zone as the low-stimulus rooms. So, if we were to apply the aspects guidelines to my trip to Mesa, the escape space at the
。因此，如果我们考虑学校设计，一个低刺激、高专注的数学教室旁边可能会挨着一个低刺激、高专注的英语教室。像音乐教室或嘈杂的食堂这样高刺激的空间不应该与低刺激的房间处于同一区域。因此，如果我们将aspects指南应用到我去梅萨的旅行中，艺术中心的逃生空间
Arts Center wouldn't be in a high-stimulus area like, say, the toilet. Or if you compartmentalize the cafe Thomas and I visited, you might get an area for quiet study tucked off to one side with no overhead lights or fans. And it wouldn't just be neurodivergent people who would benefit from thinking about design in this way. There's a name for this. It's called the curb cut effect.
就不会在像厕所这样高刺激的区域。或者，如果你对我和托马斯参观过的咖啡馆进行分区，你可能会在一侧获得一个偏安一隅的安静学习区，那里没有头顶的灯光或电扇。不仅仅是神经多样性人群会从这种设计思考中受益。这有一个名字。它被称为“路缘减速带效应”（Curb Cut Effect）。
It's when systems created to benefit a vulnerable group end up cascading to benefit everyone. Curb cuts are great for wheelchair users, but they're also a godsend for folks pushing strollers or delivery carts. Closed captioning is handy in a loud sports bar, and elevators in the subway are very convenient for anyone hauling oversized luggage.
这是指为了造福弱势群体而建立的系统最终产生连锁反应，造福了所有人。路缘减速带对轮椅使用者很棒，但它们对推婴儿车或送货推车的人来说也是天赐之福。隐藏式字幕在一个嘈杂的运动酒吧里很方便，地铁里的电梯对于任何携带超大行李的人来说都非常方便。
Now, unlike curb cuts or braille in public spaces or other accommodations required by the Americans with Disabilities Act, there is no government mandate for escape spaces or sensory zoning, at least not yet. Still, there are some new buildings that have been intentionally designed with the autistic brain in mind. Buildings that seem to reflect Magda's aspects guidelines. In 2019, the BBC opened its brand new broadcasting house in Cardiff, Wales.
现在，与路缘减速带、公共场所的盲文或《美国残疾人法案》要求的其他无障碍设施不同，政府对逃生空间或感官分区没有强制规定，至少现在还没有。尽管如此，仍有一些新建筑在设计时就有意识地将孤独症大脑考虑在内。这些建筑似乎反映了玛格达的aspects指南。2019年，英国广播公司（BBC）在威尔士加的夫开设了全新广播大楼。
The architects took neurodivergence into account when designing the interior, meaning color-coded wayfinding, private, quiet workspaces, and absolutely no flickering overhead lights. And in 2020, the new Medical University of South Carolina quiet workspaces and absolutely no flickering overhead lights. And in 2020, the new Medical University of South Carolina opened its doors aiming to be one of the most autism-friendly hospitals in the US.
建筑师在设计室内时考虑到了神经多样性，这意味着颜色编码的寻路系统、私人安静的工作空间，以及绝对没有闪烁的头顶灯光。2020年，南卡罗来纳医科大学新大楼quiet workspaces and absolutely no flickering overhead lights. And in 2020, the new Medical University of South Carolina开门营业，旨在成为美国最对孤独症友好的医院之一。
Elements of the hospital's neuro-inclusive design include adjustable lighting in patients' rooms, private play nooks in waiting areas, and a lush rooftop garden perfect for sensory seekers. But despite this progress, Magna is wary that this type of design could become a sort of thoughtless, meaningless trend. We have to be careful that people don't take the work
这家医院的神经包容性设计元素包括患者房间里的可调节照明、候诊区的小型私人游戏角落，以及非常适合寻求感官刺激者的郁郁葱葱的屋顶花园。但尽管取得了这些进展，玛格达仍然警惕这种设计可能会变成一种漫不经心、毫无意义的趋势。我们必须小心，人们不要把我们
that we're trying to do around these autism-friendly design guidance as box tickingticking, virtue-signaling tools. Right. Lip service. Like, we put some lights on a dimmer and ditched the noisy overhead fans. Boom. Autism design solved. But this type of design isn't a one-size-fits-all situation or a one-and and done. It's messy and it's not easy, but it is an opportunity to make spaces more welcoming and inclusive. And isn't that worth a little messiness?
围绕这些孤独症友好设计指南所做的努力当作勾选复选框、标榜美德的工具。没错。空头支票。就像，我们把一些灯放在调光器上，扔掉了嘈杂的头顶风扇。轰。孤独症设计问题解决。但这种设计并非千篇一律的情况，也不是一劳永逸的。它是混乱的，并不容易，但它是一个让空间变得更加热情和包容的机会。难道这不值得一点混乱吗？
And it's not just on designers and architects and neurodivergent people themselves to think about these things. It's also the responsibility of city planners and politicians to consider neuro-inclusive designs both indoors and out. Pedestrian infrastructure, public space, how people physically move from point A to point B, they all need to be addressed.
不仅是设计师、建筑师和神经多样性人群本身需要考虑这些事情。城市规划者和政治家同样有责任考虑室内外的神经包容性设计。行人基础设施、公共空间、人们如何从A点到B点进行物理移动，这些都需要得到解决。
Right now, we have a little bit of traction in individual spaces that are becoming aware, but I always say they are islands of accessibility and a sea of inaccessibility. Recently, Magda was in New York City and invited me to meet up with her at one of those islands of accessibility, the High Line, with the caveat that it's a far from perfect model. JARED BOWEN The High Line is the former elevated railroad spur turn pedestrian trail and linear park. The path hovers over the streets and snakes its way between high-end
现在，我们在开始意识到这一点的个别空间中取得了一点进展，但我总是说，它们是不accessibility的海洋中的无障碍孤岛。最近，玛格达在纽约市，邀请我在其中一个无障碍孤岛——高线公园与她会面，但她提醒说，这是一个远非完美的模型。JARED BOWEN高线公园是前高架铁路支线，现已变成步行小径和线性公园。这条小径悬浮在街道上方，在高档住宅、
apartments, office buildings, and a couple of hotels. The first phase of the High Line opened in 2009. And while it quickly became one of Manhattan's most celebrated public spaces, it's not without its critics. One called the High Line a cattle shoot for tourists. Others have rightfully noted that the park has become a symbol of New York City's rapid gentrification. Why did you bring me to this outside space? I've been thinking about a lot how what I do primarily in indoor spaces can spill out
办公楼和几家酒店之间穿梭。高线公园的第一期于2009年开放。虽然它迅速成为曼哈顿最著名的公共空间之一，但它也并非没有批评者。有人称高线公园是游客的“牛道”。其他人则理所当然地指出，这个公园已经成为纽约市快速贵族化的象征。你为什么带我来这个户外空间？我一直在思考，我主要在室内空间所做的工作如何能够溢出
and generalize outside into city spaces too. Because space, as Magda says, can't be defined in a binary way, either inside or outside. Rather, space is more of a negotiation of movement and flow and the transition between in and out. Magda and I met up at a segment of the High Line set off to the side of the main trail.
并在城市空间中向外推广。因为正如玛格达所说，空间不能以二元方式定义，非此即彼，不是内部就是外部。相反，空间更像是对运动、流动以及内外之间过渡的一种协商。玛格达和我在高线公园靠近主小径一侧的一段路上碰面了。
It hangs a little more than a story over the street and offers a little refuge from the pedestrian traffic of the path. She calls it the perch. If you're overwhelmed and to get that little minute to have a breather and even just rest, sit down, take a moment, I think it's really helpful, but I just wish there was more of it. Are there other spots along here that feel to you like they embody the principles of your work? Like the whole idea of having this parallel pathway that's quieter, softer, has some landscape, has some pockets of space that you can retreat to, I call it a sensory pathway. As we walked, I asked Magda about the diversity
它高出街道一个多楼层，为小径的行人交通提供了一个避难所。她称之为“高地平台”。如果你不堪重负，想花那一分钟喘口气，甚至只是休息一下，坐下来，花点时间，我认为这真的很有帮助，但我只是希望这样的地方能更多一些。这里还有其他地方让你觉得体现了你工作中的原则吗？比如拥有这条更安静、更柔和、有一些景观、有一些你可以退守的空间口袋的平行小径的整个想法，我称之为感官小径。在我们散步的时候，我问玛格达关于高线公园
of materials used on the High Line. Part of the path was metal, another part was wood, and still another was concrete. But it's cool because just from a visual perspective, like you're not encountering the same thing. You know, it's not like an endless bridge where you feel like, oh my God, it'll never end. Right.
使用材料的多样性。小径的一部分是金属的，另一部分是木头的，还有一部分是混凝土的。但这很酷，因为从视觉角度来看，你不会遇到相同的东西。你知道，这不像是一座无休止的桥，让你觉得，哦天哪，它永远不会结束。没错。
It breaks it up, it compartmentalizes it. Oh, there you go. See? Explain further. So like breaking things up into these little sensory zones that are manageable, I'm certain that that wasn't the intent, but it just gives you a sense of domain and boundary. So the Highline sort of accidentally
它把空间打破了，进行了分区。哦，原来如此。看吧？请进一步解释。就像把事情分解成这些小型的、易于管理的感官区域一样，我确信这不是初衷，但它确实给了你一种领域感和边界感。所以高线公园某种程度上意外地
hit some of Magda's aspects design goals. What about from a sound perspective, acoustics up here, like you can hear the city, but it's like at a remove. Right, like we're just walking by this tree. The nature just softens it really nicely. I think all the natural elements do a good job. Once you get to a place where there's wood and that absorbs a little bit more sound than the metal parts. Even if it was inadvertent at the High Line, you could definitely see autism-friendly design in action.
达到了玛格达的aspects设计目标。从声音的角度来看，这里的声学效果如何，你能听到城市的声音，但感觉它被隔开了一段距离。没错，就像我们刚刚走过这棵树。大自然把声音柔和地处理得很好。我认为所有的自然元素都做得很好。一旦你到了有木头的地方，那里的吸音效果就会比金属部件更好。即使在高线公园这是无意中做到的，你绝对可以看到孤独症友好设计的实际应用。
Well, minus the tourists. So designing for neurodifferences, indoors and out, is indeed possible. Magda and her contemporaries who think about inclusive architecture are just barely scratching the surface of autism-friendly design. There's so much more to dream up. After the break, Lauren takes us to the future of neurodivergent-friendly design. We're back with journalist Lauren Ober on her quest to find autism pleasantville.
好吧，除了游客。因此，无论是室内还是室外，为神经差异进行设计确实是可能的。玛格达和她那些思考包容性建筑的同代人，才刚刚触及孤独症友好设计的皮毛。还有更多需要梦想的东西。休息过后，劳伦将带我们走向神经多样性友好设计的未来。我们带着记者劳伦·奥贝尔回来了，她正在寻找孤独症乐土。
Or you know, something like it. Okay, we're about to head into some pretty conceptual territory, so bear with me. Basically, if you can design both indoor and outdoor spaces to be neuro-friendly, then it stands to reason that you might just be able to design a whole city using the same principles. And I'm not the only one who believes that. In my practice, I focus on how public spaces can support everyone in a more inclusive way. Bryony Roberts is an architect in New York City. She and
或者你知道的，类似的东西。好吧，我们即将进入一些非常概念化的领域，请耐心听我讲。基本上，如果你能把室内和室外空间都设计成对神经友好，那么顺理成章地，你或许也可以使用相同的原则设计整个城市。而且我不是唯一一个这样认为的人。在我的实践中，我专注于公共空间如何能以更具包容性的方式支持每个人。布里约妮·罗伯茨是纽约市的一位建筑师。她和
Lindsay Harkema are partners in the feminist design collective WIP Collaborative. We came together about three years ago to work on design and research projects that focus on community engagement and really thinking about the ways that public spaces can be more equitable. They're currently working on a project called the Neurodiverse City, which reimagines New York City's public spaces, that streets, playgrounds, plazas, to better support neurodiversity. Public spaces are typically designed in a way that is quite passive, and they're sort of neutral, generic, you know, kind of a one-size-fits-all. But it's more like one-size-fits-some.
林赛·哈克马是女权主义设计集体 WIP Collaborative 的合伙人。我们大约在三年前聚在一起，致力于关注社区参与的设计和研究项目，并真正思考公共空间如何变得更加公平。他们目前正在做一个名为“神经多样性城市”的项目，该项目重新构想了纽约市的公共空间，包括街道、游乐场、广场，以更好地支持神经多样性。公共空间的典型设计方式往往相当被动，它们有点中性、通用，你知道的，有点千篇一律。但它更像是“千篇一人”。
And those some often mean cisgender, white, male, able-bodied, and neurotypical. You know, the default. So, Lindsay and Bryony are working with autistic self-advocates to document their observations about what's working and what's not working for them in public spaces. Like Magda's autism as expertise idea. Some lessons repeatedly bubbled up. Over and over again, we heard about the need for choice,
而那些“一人”通常是指顺性别、白人、男性、身体健全且神经典型的人。你知道，默认设置。所以，林赛和布里约妮正在与孤独症自我倡导者合作，记录他们对公共空间中什么对他们管用、什么不管用的观察。就像玛格达的“孤独症作为专业知识”的想法一样。一些经验教训反复涌现。我们一次又一次地听到对选择的需求，
that the neutrality of public spaces doesn't offer any choice in terms of a range of sensory stimulation, so that if someone is seeking more stimulation, whether it's tactile, visual, auditory, there's very little opportunity for that kind of engagement. And then if we're seeking less stimulation, there's also very few places to find respite and peace. Neurodiversity was inspired by the pair's previous project,
公共空间的这种中立性在感官刺激的范围内没有提供任何选择，因此如果有人寻求更多刺激，无论是触觉、视觉还是听觉，这种参与的机会都非常少。然后，如果我们寻求更少的刺激，也很少有地方可以找到喘息和平静。“神经多样性”的灵感来自于两人之前的一个项目，
a little sidewalk park called Restorative Ground that they designed and installed during the pandemic. It was in New York City's Hudson Square and definitely did not cater to the default. We thought about creating different zones within the installation that would have different spatial characteristics in order to support the idea of choice.
一个被称为“恢复性地面”的小型人行道公园，是他们在疫情期间设计并安装的。它位于纽约市的哈德逊广场，绝对不迎合默认标准。我们考虑在装置内部创建不同的区域，这些区域具有不同的空间特征，以支持选择的理念。
The 80-foot long electric orange and red structure built on top of the sidewalk had built-in tables and benches, geometric structures that encouraged play, and a hammock that provided some excellent midday napping opportunities. The park was an active environment, meaning it invited passersby to engage with it. It was the opposite of a blank, passive sidewalk. Also, it was a stark contrast to the hostile public spaces Bryony navigated with her dad
这座长达80英尺、建在人行道顶部的亮橙色和红色结构内置了桌椅、鼓励嬉戏的几何结构，以及提供绝佳午间小憩机会的Hammock（吊床）。这个公园是一个活跃的环境，这意味着它邀请过路人与之互动。这与空白、被动的行人路截然相反。此外，这与布里约妮在她父亲
after he was diagnosed with ALS. Kind of moving through the world with him made it really clear how powerful space can be in offering comfort or escape or connection to other people and how architecture can really offer a transformative opportunity to improve quality of life. If you take the restorative ground project, that structure welcomed all kinds of users to engage with the space in all kinds of ways.
被诊断出患有肌萎缩侧索硬化症（ALS）后与之共同度过的那种充满敌意的公共空间形成了鲜明对比。陪着他走过这个世界，让我真正清楚地看到，空间在提供安慰、逃避或与他人联系方面可以具有多么强大的力量，以及建筑如何真正提供变革性的机会来改善生活质量。如果你以恢复性地面项目为例，该结构欢迎各种各样的用户以各种各样的方式与空间互动。
Resting, climbing, lunching, etc. It was multifunctional and intentional because people have different needs and the look and feel of the built environment should be just as diverse as all of the human identities that are served by it. Lindsay and Brianne haven't built their neurodiverse city yet, but that's not quite the goal. Right now, they're focused on understanding how autistic people use public space. And they're hopeful that other architects, designers, and city planners see the necessity of understanding this too.
休息、攀爬、吃午餐等。它是多功能且刻意为之的，因为人们有着不同的需求，建筑环境的外观和感觉应该像为其服务的所有人类身份一样丰富多彩。林赛和布里约妮还没有建造他们的神经多样性城市，但这并不是最终目标。现在，他们专注于了解孤独症患者如何使用公共空间。他们希望其他建筑师、设计师和城市规划者也能看到理解这一点的必要性。
This autistic person just wants some calm escape spaces that aren't, you know, the accessible toilet. I am sure they will take that under advisement. And maybe one day Lauren will get her autism pleasant fill and it will dovetail with someone else's perfectly designed space and the curb cut effect will in fact be in effect and everyone will have the space that works for them. Let's not get carried away Roman.
这位孤独症患者只想要一些平静的逃生空间，而不是，你知道的，无障碍厕所。我确信他们会把这一点记在心里。也许有一天劳伦会得到她的孤独症乐土，它将与其他人完美设计的空间完美契合，而路缘减速带效应实际上也将发挥作用，每个人都会拥有适合自己的空间。罗曼，我们别太忘形了。
The reality is that there is no universal principle of design that will work for the entire autistic population. But architects like Briony Roberts and Lindsay Harkama and Magda Mostafa are inching the autistic ball up the field. Sure, the autism awareness endeavor in Mesa might be incomplete, but at least it's a recognition that there is a discrete community and that community deserves to be accommodated. Because all of us, neurodivergent or not, are a messy jumble sale of needs. So is my neurodivergent Xanadu just around the corner?
现实情况是，并没有什么适用于整个孤独症群体的普遍设计原则。但像布里约妮·罗伯茨、林赛·哈克马和玛格达·穆斯塔法这样的建筑师正在一点一点地推动孤独症事业向前发展。当然，梅萨的孤独症意识普及工作可能还不够完善，但至少它承认了存在一个独特的社区，而这个社区理应获得包容。因为我们所有人，无论是神经多样性者与否，都是需求的大杂烩。那么，我的神经多样性世外桃源就在转角处吗？
Thinks not. But at least we're in the mix, having conversations about lights that don't flicker and rooms that don't echo. 99% Invisible was reported this week by Lauren Ober and produced and edited by Nina Potuck. Mix and sound design by Martin Gonzalez. Music by Swan Real. Fact checking by Liz Boyd. Cathy Tu is our executive producer, Kurt Kolstad is the digital director, Delaney Hall is the senior editor.
觉得不是。但至少我们参与其中，正在就“不闪烁的灯光”和“不产生回音的房间”进行对话。本周的《99%隐形》由劳伦·奥贝尔报道，由妮娜·波图克制作和剪辑。混音和声音设计由马丁·冈萨雷斯完成。音乐由斯旺·里尔创作。事实核查由利兹·博伊德完成。凯西·图是我们的执行制作人，库尔特·科尔斯塔德是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔是高级编辑。
The rest of the team includes Chris Barrupe, Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Christopher Johnson, Vivian Leigh, Lash Madon, Joe Rosenberg, Gabriella Gladney, Kelly Prime, Jacob Maldonado-Medina, Sarah Bake, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of this logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. We are part of the Stitcher and SiriusXM podcast family now headquartered six blocks north, in the Pandora building, in beautiful Uptown, Oakland, California, home of the Oakland Roots Soccer Club, of which I am a proud community owner. Other teams may come and go, but the Roots are Oakland first, always. You can find us on all the usual social media sites, as well as our new Discord server.
其余的团队成员包括克里斯·巴鲁佩、杰森·德莱昂、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、克里斯托弗·约翰逊、维维安·利、拉什·马多恩、乔·罗森伯格、加布里埃拉·格拉德尼、凯利·普赖姆、雅各布·马尔多纳多-梅迪纳、莎拉·贝克，以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。这个标志的99%由斯特凡·劳伦斯创作。我们现在是 Stitcher 和 SiriusXM 播客家族的一部分，总部位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦，位于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市上城，这里是奥克兰根源足球俱乐部的大本营，我是该俱乐部的骄傲社区业主。其他球队可能会来来去去，但根源队永远立足奥克兰。你可以在所有常规社交媒体网站以及我们的新 Discord 服务器上找到我们。
It's very fun over there. I encourage you to join. There's a link to that as well as every past episode of 99PI at 99PI.org. Hit record on your voice memo now and it's going to be A, S, P, and E. Give me an A. A. We're going to do a second take. I think everyone's muted besides Kelly, which has made this the most hilarious exercise ever. I was like, why is everyone laughing? There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
那里的气氛非常有趣。我鼓励大家加入。在 99PI.org 上可以找到它的链接以及 99PI 的每一期往期节目。现在按下你的语音备忘录录音键，它将是 A、S、P 和 E。给我一个 A。A。我们要重录一遍。我想除了凯利之外大家都静音了，这让这成为了史上最搞笑的练习。我当时还在想，为什么大家都在笑。这期节目还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任意句子即可发表评论。